la parole est à monsieur alain marty
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
les attentats de vendredi soir nous ont
blessés nous touche profondément
et je pense en ce moment aux victimes
aux familles endeuillées et aux blessés
qui luttent encore pour la vie le nombre
des victimes jeunes pour la plupart
tombés sous les tirs de fanatiques
islamistes lâches et barbares a choqués
et meurtris nos concitoyens dans ma
circonscription monsieur le premier
ministre
des habitants choqué révolté en colère
me demande pourquoi nous avons attendu
ces victimes innocentes pour frapper
massivement l'état islamique en syrie
ils comprennent les frappes répétées sur
rack à ces derniers jours mais pourquoi
ne pas avoir commencé plus tôt dans ma
circonscription des habitants choqué
révolté en colère me demande après le
discours du président de la république
qui a annoncé au congrès que les forces
de l'ordre avaient mené dimanche
cent soixante huit perquisitions et 23
interpellations
pourquoi attendre qu'il y ait des
victimes innocentes pourquoi ne pas
avoir agi plus tôt
il n'y a pas de polémique dans mes
propos l'heure n'est pas à la polémique
mais il est de mon devoir de vous
transmettre les interrogations légitimes
de concitoyens effondré choqués qu'ils
ont conscience que ces attentats odieux
pouvait toucher des amis des parents des
proches de passage ou qui vivent à paris
je vous remercie de bien vouloir leur
répondre merci monsieur marty la parole
est à monsieur le premier ministre
manuel valls ce président monsieur le
député marty ses interrogations ses cris
cette colère nous l'entendons tous bien
sûr nous avons été frappés une nouvelle
fois au coeur et vous leur aviez
justement comme fleur pellerin il ya un
instant c'est la jeunesse mais je suis
frappé comme vous par les témoignages
indirects ou direct par les portraits
dans la presse de ceux et de celles qui
sont tombés des jeunes très souvent
venus de toute la france
venus du monde entier d'ailleurs ça a
été rappelé
donc nous leur devons une réponse la
première réponse c'est bien sûr agir
agir pour être efficace parce qu'il ya
la peur en même temps il ya la révolte
et ce peuple se tient debout et vous en
avez tous bien sûr dans vos
circonscriptions les témoignages c'est
frappé d'abord là où il ya le coeur en
syrie et en irak en irak où il ya
également le coeur de neige
nous sommes dans une coalition avec et
je veux le dire même si c'est long et
difficile mais parce que nous
intervenons la coalition à la demande du
gouvernement irakien
parce que nous soutenons les troupes du
gouvernement irakien mais aussi je
rappeler hier au sénat les kurdes qui
obtiennent des résultats tout à fait
extraordinaire et je veux saluer
d'ailleurs la vaillance et l'engagement
des pertes merga kurdes qui ont obtenu
les résultats repris des villes coupé la
route entre mossoul et rafa et dont nous
intervenons et nos mirage et de rafale
interviennent en syrie et en irak
nous n'avons pas attendu ces événements
pour frapper en irak et nous n'avons pas
attendu ces événements terribles pour
frapper en également en syrie mais nous
savons que nous seuls nous ne pouvons
pas gagner cette guerre là bas et qu'il
faut entraîner une coalition je
rappelais il ya un instant en répondant
à meyer habib le ministre des affaires
étrangères le faisait aussi en répandant
à la présidente elisabeth guigou c'est
cette coalition contre l'ennemi contre
dèche neige qui a frappé la russie la
russie qui a reconnu enfin hier fin qui
a admis qui a considéré que l'attentât
qui avait subi que cet avion d'une
compagnie russe avait été l'objet d'un
attentat revendiqué par des ch
c'est toute la communauté internationale
qui doit se mobiliser et pousse qui nous
concerne en france
nous devons poursuivre amplifié
approfondir la lutte contre le
terrorisme de loi antiterroriste la loi
sur le renseignement
une nouvelle voie sur une nouvelle loi
sur l'enseignement qui est examiné
actuellement par le conseil
constitutionnel des moyens en hommes
pour la police la gendarmerie nos
services de renseignement pour nos
militaires pour les douanes pour les
services pénitentiaires des moyens en
investissement et c'est essentiel que
puissions investir encore davantage pour
les forces de l'ordre en armes en
protection en véhicule en équipement en
nouvelles technologies
c'est un changement ce changement nous
le portons et ils chacun en est
convaincu l'effort que la nation écoute
les pays qui sont confrontés au
terrorisme
l'effort que la france devra faire en
matière de sécurité et de défense dans
les cinq et dix ans qui viennent ce sera
un effort considérable qui change
d'ailleurs notre vision budgétaire c'est
pour ça qu'il fallait augmenter et
donner de nouveau des moyens aux forces
de l'ordre c'est ainsi avec la loi que
nous voterons demain avec la possible
révision constitutionnelle si nous
trouvons le moyen de nous mettre
d'accord et j'en suis convaincu c'est
ainsi que nous avançons et que nous
répondre à toutes ces questions
légitimes que vous posent nos
compatriotes et notre devoir
bien sûr le devoir impérieux le devoir
sacré c'est d'y répondre à nos
compatriotes et en ayant en mémoire tous
les victimes qui sont tombés tous les
victimes qui sont tombés à cause du
terrorisme
merci monsieur le premier la parole est
à monsieur arnaud